wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you do
you have michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the seven best
lessons from jeff bezos oprah winfrey
and other billionaire entrepreneurs
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one be realistic with jeff bezos
once you
are looking at the odds in a realistic
way it's very important for
entrepreneurs to be realistic and so if
you believe
on that first day while you're writing
the business plan that there's a 70
chance that the whole thing will fail
and you know
then that kind of relieves the pressure
of of self-doubt i mean it's sort of
like i don't have any doubt about
whether we're going to feel that's the
likely outcome
um and it just is and to pretend that
it's not will lead you to do strange and
you know uh
unnatural things
so we uh
you know and what you do with those
early investment dollars you know so if
you have 300 000 and then you have a
million dollars what you do with those
early precious capital resources is you
go about systematically trying to
eliminate risk so you pick whatever the
you know you think the biggest problems
are you try to eliminate them one at a
time
and that's uh that's how small companies
get a little bit bigger and then a
little bit bigger and a little bit
bigger until finally at a certain stage
you reach a transition where you
have where the company has more control
over its future destiny you know and
when a company is very tiny it needs a
tremendous amount of not only hard work
but as we talked about earlier luck
as a company gets bigger
it starts to become a little more stable
where if the you know at a certain point
in time the company
has a much bigger influence over its
future outcome it needs a lot less luck
and instead it needs the hard work and
at that point in a way at that point
there's a little bit more pressure
because then if you fail you have nobody
to blame but yourself lesson number two
fear nothing with tillman fertitta tell
people your your concept of the paddle
well there's a paddle for everybody's
ass we all know that and uh every day
you just get up and i don't fear
anything but i'll worry about everything
and the day you stop worrying in good
times
the paddle will get you behind and and
and so as great as things are in life
i'm i know you're only a few steps or a
few incidents away from something bad
happening you can never forget it did
you have fear as a kid and you just got
into enough business scuffles that you
figured your way through things or have
you always
been fearless i'm pretty fearless but i
do worry about everything but
you know once again you know the book
and this is why harper's asked me to
write the book because of all my
tillmanisms you got to know what you
know and what you don't know
and and i knew that i understood
business now don't ask me to you know go
win an emmy i took guitar lessons for
four years and i still struggle playing
a guitar i can't draw a stick person
very good but i knew that i understood
business so i i know what i know and i
know how to do due diligence on a deal i
don't worry about making a bad deal
because i feel like
that's what i know so
no fear when it comes to that lesson
number three be passion driven with
oprah winfrey for me
i've already made more money than i
expected i've already got more shoes
than i know
and i'm like okay what to do with the
shoes
you know so and it never was about
material possessions i don't think if i
could have uh
if i'd sat down
and said how do i dream myself up to be
able to get all this i wouldn't have
known how to do it so i was driven by a
passion that was bigger than the show in
the beginning and i believe that in
order to continue every person has a
responsibility to use their life
you
everybody who came here today your life
may not be as big as mine meaning not as
many people know you and the only
difference between being famous and not
is that more people know your name the
real reality is what uh billy was
singing and what um maddie talks about
in his poetry is that we are really all
alike
except for our hair we are really
we are really all alike and that has
been one of the greatest lessons i've
learned in doing this television show is
that what everybody is looking for
is validation yeah in every experience
people are looking to know that they
matter that you matter that i matter in
every encounter and all your fights at
home
all your arguments with your boss or
with your children with your husband
when you really peel back the layers and
get down to what is what is this what
are we arguing about you're arguing you
want to say i matter and i think that um
what we've been able to do on this show
is to help people see that for
themselves and if i can be able to give
that back to people in a way that makes
them matter to themselves then this is
worth
billions of dollars
it's priceless it's priceless to be able
to do that also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video i've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the lessons
learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business i'll see you there
lesson number four focus on learning
with mark cuban the first question
you're going to get asked when you go to
apply for a job whether it's now or some
point in the future is what did you
learn what did you do what skills did
you add during the pandemic of 2020 and
i think it's imperative to anybody
looking to to get a job to really push
themselves forward to do better than
their parents to really place a focus on
learning you know i i think you'd agree
mike and anybody watching that one of
the greatest skills that we all can have
in the in the business world is a thirst
for knowledge just being excited about
learning and knowing how to learn and
this really is the best opportunity ever
for people to add to their skills
whether it's taking a coursera class or
you know in the past i would have said
reading a lot of books but now having
learned from my kids going on youtube
and you know watching
tutorials and watching videos on various
subjects you know i learned how to write
a three-letter three-layer javascript
neural network on youtube and so there's
a unique opportunity now for you to add
skills particularly in areas like
artificial intelligence that are going
to be in great demand that most people
have not yet learned because you know
it's it's so recent that it's become
really applicable lesson number five
think critically with elon musk and just
in general critical thinking is is good
you know examining whether you have the
correct axioms are the most applicable
axioms
does the logic necessarily connect
and then
what are the what are the range of
probable outcomes
outcomes are usually not deterministic
they're
they're they're a range
and so you want to figure out what those
probabilities are and make sure
ideally that you're the house
you know it's fine to take
it's fine it's fine to gamble as long as
you're the house lesson number six be
omnipresent with grant cardone what are
your best three marketing tips
uh to number one is be everywhere all at
the same time
it's called omnipresence
so
omnipresence anything that's the
omnipresence by the way has survived for
since
the the beginning of man 300 000 years
or whatever
whoever can be everywhere will be
assigned power
whether it's the queen or god or
coca-cola
whatever can be everywhere
will be assigned power
and so omnipresence with marketing this
has really never been possible before
until the digital age the last six or
seven years
facebook instagram snapchat youtube
these things that
based on the age of this audience half
of you probably don't use
you know because you're like i don't
have time for that this well-dressed man
right here with the sweater and the
glasses over his nose and this man this
man this very aristocratic
looking gentleman okay he are you on
facebook sir
he's on facebook that's unbelievable
instagram
no youtube
i mean you have a youtube channel i
don't mean you watch my youtube
you have your own youtube channel
okay that's pretty good
so but but you see like like you should
the answer to your question is be
omnipresent two use all channels all of
them everything i'm gonna use youtube
snapchat linkedin twitter
i'm going to use
newspapers
even though most people aren't reading
newspapers i'm going to use magazines
i'm going to use
that's that's marketing i'm going to use
expo events like this
events like
stages like this i'm going to use
telephone calls cold calling warm
calling
i'm going to use billboards if you go to
miami right now you'll see 28 massive
billboards throughout
miami a million dollars worth of
marketing material where i'm introducing
where i live
the business owners to my name
so i would use every um
marketing means possible
lastly the number three thing is i would
have
your marketing budget
be
have a target of your last year's income
i would spend more money on marketing
than i do people and i would spend more
money on people than than i could even
imagine i would just spend more money
and lesson number seven the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
be persistent with vinod khosla the
funny thing is with enough persistence
most things that seem impossible
become possible
uh i'm always amazed at how often you
can turn things around
and people take no for an answer too
easily
you know it's whether you're trying to
achieve a goal like get into business
school
or
my green card was the same way i left
the job
that it sponsored me but i still got my
green card even though no lawyer would
take me i became my own lawyer
got my green card without working for
while i was at business school
um
and i did it perfectly legally i my
strategy there was if i couldn't
convince immigration i'd confuse them
and i did
and they gave me my green card now i've
got a special bonus clip that i think
are going to enjoy but before that it's
time for the good deed of the day this
is something new i believe that you were
built to serve and it feels so good to
do something nice for somebody else so
good deed of the day put down in the
comments one thing that you need help
with that you're working on you'd love
some support or guidance on and then two
go
comment on somebody else's comment and
give them some love give them some
support give them some encouragement
maybe give them some connections try to
help them solve that problem even if
it's saying i believe in you that one
little bit of encouragement can be the
difference between somebody quitting and
continuing on so the good deed of the
day in the comments below write down one
thing that you need help on that you're
struggling with that you're working on
and then part two is go give love to
somebody else in the comments too and
let them know that you believe in them
as well what would you say is the best
advice that you could give other people
from what you learned about making their
first million bucks so say somebody's
making six
figures up and that's just do the math
you know what's what's first of all do
you want to make a million
or do you want to keep a million
they're completely they're like 60
difference between those two questions
right so specificity in the goal you
want to make everybody's go everybody
watching is going to make a million
dollars i mean if you live
25 years you're going to make a million
dollars 25 times 40 000 bucks bang you
made a million dollars if that's your
goal so this is what i talked about in
the 10x rule the goals people are
setting
are incorrect and that's why people give
up on their goals
because
i know so many guys that hit a million
dollars
like i've had so many people come to me
and say i hit a million
and i lost the juice yeah it got
comfortable almost yeah a lot of guys in
network marketing tell me this like i
was in network marketing i became a
million dollar producer
just lost it because the goal was wrong
the goal was wrong first of all it
wasn't your goal
anybody's got a million dollar target
it's not your goal you adopted this goal
this idea from somebody else
because the number any number that ends
in zero is a lazy number
the chance is a number ending in zero is
almost mathematical what a great point
what a great point so it's a lazy
concept you just adopted somebody else's
idea i want to be a millionaire would do
you have even done the math do the math
on a million dollars it's no money this
is what people
they they like god hate grant
because your target was a million
you're struggling making 200. you think
a million is impossible
you don't want me to tell you the truth
and the truth is it is no money as soon
as you get it i read the book the
millionaire next door almost everybody
read that book back in the 90s
it was the best book for me
because it taught me
i don't want to be a millionaire
it lifted the lid i'm like i don't want
to be the guy buying a ford truck i
don't want a ford truck man
right i got to buy a ford truck a used
ford truck f-150
so one day i could be a millionaire yeah
and i can't go get coffee i need to
bring a brown pack to my office every
day not drink coffee at the shop
in order to be a millionaire well the
reason i knew that was not good for me
was because my dad died at 52
with a little bit of money
and i'm like i don't want to die
with money when i'm old
i want to have enough money
and that that undid everything for me i
want financial freedom i don't want to
hit a quota
you know and i think everybody's
struggling for the quota they're
struggling for the bills they set their
financial plan based on what their
spending is or what their apartment
costs or what the mortgage is rather or
what their kids need rather than i want
freedom i don't want financial literacy
i want financial freedom
you know so i hear people say oh we need
to teach financial literacy no you need
to teach financial freedom the
possibility of it what would i need how
much
you know this whole cash flow thing that
i talk about all the time cash flow is
the holy grail of finance
that's why his business works that's why
he's able to enjoy the lifestyle he has
he has
financial freedom not a money number
what are your core values personally and
professionally
core values are i would say it's the
golden rule
do unto others as you would have others
do unto you that's the basis for most
religions but they get sometimes carried
away in rights and rituals but that's
the core value do unto others as you'd
have others do unto you
and then it's the feeling of knowing
that success unshared is definitely
failure in other words when you make it
it's not really just about yourself
making it hey if you make it you know
you made it but along the way one of the
great lessons to learn
is it's not all about you
it's about your ability to be of service
to this planet while you're here and by
saying me me me me look what i did this
is me hey here's my building my name's
on it you know i did this you didn't by
doing something like that it kind of
takes away from how genuine you are and
because people don't like to just listen
to people talk about themselves how
great they are they want to know
incorporate it to make them successful
also or do something a little different
and i think that's very very important i
teach them that there is no life without
cultivating a spiritual life
because you are first and foremost a
spiritual being having a human
experience
and if you lose sight of that it's easy
to get lost in the world and no one can
save a world that they're lost in when
they've lost sight of their own north
star
so having a spiritual life actually
means actively and ritually creating the
space in your life all the time for
gratitude for kindness for empathy for
inspiration for joy and for reverence
for life in the home of your soul first
and then working to spread that inner
joy outward
it means
slowing down it means taking in the
moment it means being exactly where you
are
not distracted somewhere else it means
knowing who you are and getting about
the business of fulfilling why you
really came to our planet how aside from
making great products how do you get
people excited about tesla there's a lot
of people i know and that i talk to who
are just intrigued and interested and
excited about tesla as a company the
thing i really focus on at tesla is like
we really put all the money into an
attention to trying to make the product
as compelling as possible so um because
i think that really the way to
sell any product is through word of
mouth so if if
one somebody gets the car they really
like it they and and actually the key is
like to have a product that people love
um and and generally people
that um you know if that a party or
tour friends or whatever um you'll talk
about the things that you love
but you know if you just like something
it's okay you're not gonna care that
much but if you get the reactions from
the highs and the lows yeah you got to
make sure you have a really good you're
going to
you're going to talk you know and and
then that'll generate work during word
of mouth that's basically how how our
sales have have grown like we don't
we're not spending money on advertising
or endorsements or
uh and um so anyone like buys our car
they just bought it because they they
like the car and you know it's like it's
genuine how do you deal with failure and
what's your advice to young
entrepreneurs like me in this case
especially with regards to failure and
how to approach it yeah well if you
if you fail you really do dust yourself
off and you know get right back in i
mean you're going to fail at some things
you're going to have some human
relationships that don't work out
you know
fairly significant number of people get
divorced i mean and you know that's a
very big decision to have turn out badly
but uh
i think if you study
almost everybody and read read kay's
book you know personal history and
you'll everybody
fails at some things i mean you know
particularly
particularly when you're younger i mean
you know you do have less experience in
evaluating humans and you know and and
just knowing about whatever it may be
businesses uh but you know it it is not
fatal i mean if you're healthy
and
you live in this particularly living in
this country there's gonna be there's
gonna be an opportunity that comes along
uh uh i got turned down for the harvard
business school uh when i was uh when i
got on the university of nebraska you
know and i remember you know i went to
chicago to get interviewed this is when
you traveled on the train and so i spent
10 hours going there and this fellow
looked at me and about 10 minutes he
said you know forget it bell
and now i got to go back on the train 10
hours and think
what am i going to tell my dad what i
want to tell my dad i mean my dad always
told me i could do anything and
everything now i've just got just gotten
turned down uh you know but it turned
out that one of the best things ever
happened to me because then i went to
columbia where ben graham was it in fact
it probably even affected who i married
because i took a one-year course at
columbia and said two years at harvard
and she might have found some other guy
during that time
almost everything in my life
that looked like a failure has either
turned
well usually it's turned into a success
i mean it
it the world isn't over you know
if you have bad luck in health that
that's tough i mean that there's just no
there's just no getting away i've been
lucky on that but but
the other kind of things if you're
healthy and you're bright and you know
you've got decades ahead of you
you know if
something goes wrong if you find
yourself working for the wrong employer
and they're you know they're doing
things you don't approve of or they're
not treating you fairly you know the
world isn't over yet you know you just
go out
and find somebody else well when i went
back to china in 1995 with an idea of
internet was very strange china was not
connected to the internet
so i tried to talk to a lot of my
friends that what is internet nobody say
ah this thing never work this thing
never exists
um
because it's true because nobody but
people even say jack is alive because
he's trying to steal money from people
telling us there is the internet so when
i go to
when i go to the china red
company registration office
i said i want to register company called
hanzo hope
internet company
the guy looked at me say
this is the
english dictionary tell me there's no
there's no word called the internet why
you want a registered company called the
internet
so i cannot register name a company name
but
it i in
1995 in later
august china was connected the internet
i was number seven person connected to
the in china internet
in order to prove
i was not a lie
i invited my friend who is a tv man
take the tv camera they all stay in my
home
and we
they just try to take the picture i i
die from hangzhou to shanghai shanghai
to america to connect the internet it
took us
three hours and a half to download the
first front of the page
at that time there is no net escape
called the mosaic
oh
so ever i have to make like a hundred
stars to keep my journalists friends to
stay and wait because to prove that i'm
not telling a lie but you've never been
shy to speak up in issues that are
important to you and one of those themes
i've found has been around fairness
and whether that's you know calling out
referees for not calling games
consistently or you know calling out a
shark tank contestant because you think
that they're scamming their customers
how do you decide what you're going to
speak up on or do you hold inside you
know it's changed over the years um
because i have kids
because social media you know twitter in
particular is so much different um and
has changed kind of the rules of
engagement
um
it's changed because of what i went
through with the mavericks last year i
missed a sexual harassment problem that
we had because i wasn't i took my eye
off the ball
um
and so you know i try to be self-aware
and try to put myself in the shoes of
the person or people or organization i'm
talking about whether it
adds value
i try to put myself in the position my
own position you know how's it going to
be perceived and you know
is it worth it you know will it create
more good
than
challenges
and and so you've got to pick your spots
this work-life harmony thing is what i
try to teach young employees actually
and senior executives at amazon too but
especially the people coming i get we're
asked about work-life balance all the
time
and my view is that's a debilitating
phrase
because
it um
it implies there's a strict trade-off
and the reality is if i'm happy at home
i come into the office with tremendous
energy and if i'm happy at work i come
home with tremendous energy and so it
actually is a circle it's not a balance
and um and i think that that is uh
is worth everybody paying attention to
you want to have you never want to be
that guy and we all know we all have a
co-worker
who is that person who as soon as they
come into the meeting they drain all the
energy out of the room
you can just feel the energy level go
that you don't want to be that guy so
you want to come into the office and
give everybody a kick in their step you
know i got
an awful lot of good advice from my dad
and and he didn't he didn't lay it on me
i mean he just
you know you you you picked it up from
him but there was never any of this you
know do this do that
type of thing at all but but
i think he really taught me that it's
more important
uh in terms of what's on your inner
score card than your outer score card i
mean some people
get in a position where they they're
thinking all of the time of what what
the world's going to think of this or
that instead of what they themselves
think about and if
if your inner score card if you're if
you're comfortable with that
uh i think you're gonna you're gonna
have a pretty happy life and i think the
people that strive too much for the
outer scorecard
sometimes find it it's a little hollow
when they get all through the hardest
thing for me early on
was you know because i i just started
off as i was
i was an engineer or you know i wasn't
even really an engineer as a student
right it's i i thought i was going to be
an engineer when i graduated and
you know when you're when you're
building something yourself
you kind of have all the meetings in
your head right it's like you don't need
to articulate the principles so clearly
it's like you kind of can make all the
trade-offs on on everything from
architecture to product to marketing to
you know just all these things and
you're kind of just you have the context
to trade this off
and
i think it's really
easy when you start
building something to um
to underestimate
how much context you need to put out
there and how clear you need to be about
what you're trying to do so you know
most of my mistakes early on in building
the company
were about not being clear enough
internally about what we were trying to
do and there's this very famous
you know episode where
where like
in 2006 a couple years into building the
company
um yahoo tried to buy us and
so they offered a ton of money
and
a lot of the people who who i'd hired at
the point they were kind of experienced
technology executives and this was like
all of their startup dream come true
right they joined and then you know
within you know a year or a few months
like the the company had the opportunity
to exit for this large amount of money
and
you know i really
failed through that period to
communicate what we were trying to do
and what we
what we stood for
and
in the absence of that
that context then of course it was a
rational thing for people to think that
this was like a good outcome for us to
have sometimes it's like god has other
plans it's like something hits you and
you don't even know and well frankly the
things going through my mind were what's
you know what's what's going on what's
wrong with me uh uh i would try i would
spend my makeup trying to cover it up
because rosacea's bright red and you get
these um patches on your skin and
they're textured like sandpaper
right almost yes and it's very textured
and so um no i mean i think any time
you know something happens to us whether
it's a physical thing a physical change
an emotional
situation um something with our health
right anytime we have something like
that you know the the
it's hard
to go through the the beginning of it
because i struggled a little bit
honestly i had thoughts like okay
am i pretty anymore like just those
things like i'm embarrassed i never even
said that out loud by the way but like
that's the truth i just started doubting
myself i started um
doubting okay is this going to affect my
career you know but
in in the midst of the the start of kind
of that that i guess struggle of going
okay
my physical appearance is changing let
me wrap my head around this um uh is
when i started really looking into
makeup and and trying everything out
there spending my tiny paycheck on on uh
every product i could get my hands on
from the most expensive to least
expensive and and uh there's that famous
saying like you know sometimes we make
our mess our message and that's sort of
what happened it was this
entrepreneurial moment where
i realized there's nothing out there
that works for me right nothing that
will solve my problem and there must be
so many other people that have just
given up on makeup because it doesn't
work for them and it's like okay
nothing works and and
the more i researched i'm like wow
seventy percent of women have
hyperpigmentation now
all of us yeah yeah that's like oh you
know what i mean and so many of us deal
with just all different uh things
hormonal changes everything acne and so
i just thought you know what
if i can solve this problem for me i
know that it could be you know of
service and life-changing for for other
people also
i actually think you should think twice
before starting certain types of
businesses so i think um there are
probably too many bad businesses getting
started and not enough good ones so
that's it's um you know i don't think
there's i don't think there's anything
about entrepreneurship per se
that is um
that is is good you know i was telling
one of my friends a few years ago i was
asking him what do you want to be doing
in five or ten years oh it's really
clear i want to be an entrepreneur
that's like saying i want to be rich i
want to be famous
um and i i don't think
i don't those are those are good things
being rich and famous um they're not
good as direct goals like if if you if
you have that as your sole goal you're
unlikely to i think really uh really
succeed and so i think you become an
entrepreneur because you're working on
an important problem nobody else is
working on i think you should start a
business if you have
something if you're if you're working on
a problem that otherwise would not get
solved introverts can do quite well
[Applause]
i think that there's
you know if you're
clever you can learn
to get the benefits of being an
introvert which might be say being
willing to go off for a few days and
think about a tough problem
read everything you can push yourself
very hard to think out on the edge of
that area
and then
if you come up with something if you
want to hire people get them excited
build a company around that idea
you better learn what extroverts do you
better hire some extroverts
like steve ballmer i would claim as an
extrovert
and tap into both sets of skills in
order to have a company that uh that
thrives both as in deep thinking and
building teams and and going out into
the world to sell those ideas one of the
reasons we have been able to extend into
new business areas and first new product
categories going way back we just sold
books and then we started selling music
and dvds and electronics and toys and so
on and then we've extended
into
electronic reading with kindle
the reason customers have been receptive
in large part to our new initiatives is
because we have worked hard to earn
trust with them
earning trust with customers
is
is a valuable business asset and if you
uh mistreat their data
they will no they will figure it out
customers are very smart you should
never underestimate customers if you
could go back and talk to your younger
self
go built the time machine and go back
and talk to your younger self what what
advice would you give the younger you
that maybe you didn't realize about
yourself that you wish you did when you
were younger
well the first thing that pops into my
mind is that he shows up
he shows up he shows up and i think he's
sitting in the audience here but i spent
a lot of time as a younger self worrying
about
am i going to meet the right one am i
going to be able to have children am i
going to start a family and i would tell
my younger self just chill out he shows
up just do your thing don't spend any
mental energy on that but it's hard you
know especially as a woman i really
wanted to be financially independent i
wanted to chart my own way but i also
was really wanting to to be a mother and
have another side of my life so that's
what i would say very good he shows up
he took his time i didn't get married
till i was 37 38
but now we have four children very good
you can't get what you want by focusing
on what you don't want
this is about the need to
establish
as many meaningful connections as we can
if we're going to save the world we have
to find a way to connect to each other
to connect to the nature that we're
killing to animals to history to an
acknowledgement of the lingering trauma
of racism and sexism we need to connect
to the people we love and mean something
to us and more than that to the people
who don't
that doesn't mean we always have to
agree with another person's philosophy
it means
we if we're going to continue to survive
and thrive on this planet have to find
ways to transcend the politics of
division and embrace the places that
bond us where we find our human ground
what motivations do people need to
harness to try to make change as opposed
to just reading about change
um
and that's not supposed to be an easy
question
oh it's it's this
well
like i said i think if
if you study engineering and and you
figure out how to design new things um
then
it's relatively easy to start a company
um
you just need to get a few like-minded
people um with you and and then focus on
creating a prototype for compelling
prototype as soon as possible um and
then that you know there's a there's a
strong venture uh capital industry in
this this country that will give you
funding to take things to the next level
um and that that's all there is to it um
and you might if you try it a few times
you might may or may not succeed but um
i think sometimes people fear fear
starting a company too much um you know
they have to say really what's worse
that could go wrong you're not going to
stop to death you're not going to die of
exposure
what's the worst that could go wrong you
made an interesting decision when you
started uh microsoft not to have dual a
dual class share
um and so many of these silicon valley
companies do today
what do you think of that i think it's a
mistake and i've said that to everyone
who's asked me it's enough
as an individual to really feel like
you're responsible for the success of a
company
to actually go and short circuit the
governance mechanism where if you really
are making mistakes that your board
can't outvote you that you literally can
just replace the board the next day
how kind of hubris is that i mean if
you're really doing a good job you
really think you're at risk of that i
didn't want i felt enough responsibility
for making sure microsoft succeeded that
i didn't want to be the dictator of
microsoft how did you get through like
tactically to a sale in the encyclopedia
world like people don't want to hear
from you so like how do you overcome
that
what a question asked me
the average encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days
i was at it for three and a half years
and the way it worked in those days it
was commission only so the way it worked
is you went for an interview they told
you all you could possibly make off
commission only and we were in training
for three days it was a presentation
that was scripted we'd have to memorize
the whole thing when you got in the
field you remember parts of it you knock
on doors you're not quite sure of
yourself a lot of doors are closed in
your face but what happens after a while
you start getting used to it and you see
what you can say or do
that'll make it better but when you go
back the next day with your other
salespeople what you see what you do
what did i say
uh so let's say knock on 100 door skin
into one give 10 presentations to sell
one book but then when you get better
and better at it through your
experiences and losses along the way
it sharpens you up where all of a sudden
i got to a point where if i gave three
presentations i have no less than one
order commission only but i believe that
i could do that i believe that colleges
were the best set of books because a
high school student could read it it
wasn't like a college manual you had to
read and i was doing something good for
somebody so you have to believe that
what you're doing is good is going to
benefit somebody and you learn as you go
okay do i look someone in the eye see a
lot of people know these things look
someone in the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye because you feel
uncomfortable of course you do they're
not on the same wavelength you're on or
the same frequency so what do you do how
do you overcome that you learn these
things along the way you look them right
between the eyes or their eyebrows looks
like you're looking over the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh there's all these things
and of course smile smile's the most
wonderful thing god gave us and you
don't smile when you first talk to
somebody you smile before you knock on
their door
and if your day sucks you fake it
hi how you doing so when you smile
everything changes people change are
there any leadership principles um
you know that that have contributed to
your success as a leader not as an
entrepreneur
leader does never fix the style
right some leaders good speaking some
leader never speak by actions
leader leadership doesn't have style
everybody can be a leader a good leader
should have a vision
the vision is that vision not
necessarily good because when i work in
the company
when everybody was disappointed i have
to tell them i have to see before the
other people see the opportunity where
everybody excited i have seen the
disaster
especially as a ceo of like a me in the
alibaba group my job is to see the
problems of the future
so
and kill the problems before the
disaster comes so a leader must have a
vision speaking of learning from lessons
you've been around a lot of incredible
entrepreneurs and i know you did a
reality show with richard branson says
10 12 years ago you said yes
what was that like and what's been a big
lesson you've learned from him and what
was the show and
what'd you learn yeah the show was
called the rebel billionaire and it was
the apprentice version richard branson's
version of that they were looking for 16
entrepreneurs so i'm like hey i'm an
entrepreneur i want to do this and i
really wanted to meet richard i sort of
had set intentions out there that i was
going to manifest him becoming a friend
in my life so when i heard about the
show i was like oh this is interesting
this might be how this happens so i
applied for it and
it was wild so it's how big how big was
spanx at the time was it really well
known was it like just kind of it was
pretty i mean it was four years in it
was doing great yeah multiple seven
figures yeah my lawyers begged me not to
do it they're like what are you doing
you own this company you're gonna do a
reality show i was like i just want to
know richard i just feel like this is a
chance so um
so
yeah and and all the business challenges
took place around the world in different
cities and instead of if you didn't win
the business challenge going into a
board room to get fired you had to do a
crazy stunt like a world record breaking
stunt because richard is obviously
like a huge adrenaline junkie guy
so um in addition to being an amazing
entrepreneur and the very first day of
filming i had to climb the side of a hot
air balloon at 9 000 feet in the air on
a dangling rope ladder and have tea
climb to the top and have tea on top of
the balloon with richard it's insane
it's insane what did you guys talk about
on top oh my god talked about like how
do we get down and that's what he said
you climbed back down i was like what i
didn't think about that it was so scary
yeah oh my gosh yeah so it took me 48
minutes to climb to the top it's at the
height of a 17-story building and the
dangling rope ladder was just like
hanging out into the abyss of
nothingness wasn't anchored to anything
so i'm like climbing it
and um there's cameras that was the
first day of filming so two months later
i know i like cameras up there
yes
helicopters
i had to do all these crazy stunts the
next stone i had to do is i had to jump
off the side of the victoria falls gorge
in africa
on a with a bungee cord attached to me
and
my
guy on my team was dangling on a wire on
a crane
10 feet out from the cliff and each
person had to come up and stand there
and you couldn't run and jump and you
had to stand still and jump and if he
caught you you were okay and they'd put
you back on the cliff and if not you
fell 385 feet
on a bungee cord
and so i am be on terrified of heights
it's like one of my i'm so afraid of
heights i cry on airplanes still during
takeoff a lot of times
and
i was one of the only people to make the
jump richard didn't make the jump all
these other guys that were like amazing
athletes didn't make the jump and i like
to talk about this because i always talk
about aiming high and the importance of
aiming high in life and that i think all
of us we don't aim high enough
and so watch where you're aiming and
that that's saying you know if you shoot
for the moon if you miss you're at least
with the stars and afterwards everyone
was like sarah how did you make that
jump you're literally like the only
contestant look at you i said well i was
aimed at the pulley six feet above his
head where were you aiming and i aimed i
didn't even look at him i aimed six feet
above his head and i landed at his waist
and he caught me and everybody else was
aiming at his face and landed at his
feet and missed
amazing so it's like a really just
poignant
example of the importance of aiming high
in all areas of life yeah
my dad busted his ass i mean he worked
six six days a week um
left at seven at seven seven thirty in
the morning got back at six or seven
o'clock um lost his eye in an accident
doing upholstery he had a staple break
when he was putting um
some
covering on a car seat
um
you know it was it was a middle class
uprinking my mom did odd jobs
you know they they just wanted something
better i mean my grandparents came over
from russia and you know my dad was the
first generation my uncles were the
first generation americans like my mom
too and you know like every child of
immigrants they wanted better for their
kids you know it's funny i mean a lot of
people grow up that way right but not
many people end up like you so what do
you think that's the result of
i think
you know
everybody's got something that they're
good at and the hard part is just
finding it
and i found out early that i was a good
salesperson that i really liked business
you know like i like sports i mean i
read everything i possibly could played
sports as much as i could just wasn't as
good as i wanted to be and and business
was the same way i mean as long as i
could remember i was buying and selling
baseball cards garbage bags
whatever i could find stamps
to collectors
but i was also reading everything i
possibly could about business and you
know i was that unusual kid that i'd
rather read about ted turner than go to
the movies and and so i think that
created a foundation of my parents you
know my dad used to always say i don't
understand what you're doing
but i'm glad you're doing it and and so
i had my ups and downs along the way of
course but um i just think that i just i
just put in the time and was fortunate
enough to really get excited about
business and that paid off benefits over
the long haul two weeks ago i went i
went uh plant only
plant-based plant-based how does that
feel i dropped the meat dude that's so i
want to do that i did that for a week
last week yeah and i felt amazing i had
a lot more gas just from all the plants
i think but cleaning it out
that's really too much information for
me
but i've had uh way more energy yeah but
like and less inflammation and less pain
yeah i had noticed i have a little bit
of inflammation in in my hands but yeah
that hadn't hadn't changed but
the plant-based thing i watched the game
the the game changer yeah
and uh when he said
dude you're eating the middleman
like when i heard that that was enough
for me right eating the middleman you're
eating the middleman
meaning the cow the cow eats the grass
right you can go eat go right
the source is the grass yeah and as soon
as i heard that i'm like what the [ __ ]
am i doing eating the middleman
i ain't a middleman guy i want to go
directly to the source
where all the energy's at yeah i mean
like like any that was the line in the
show that did me and i had been thinking
about it too i've eaten meat for 60
years i grew up on bacon
four pieces of bacon every day so good
uh oh yeah totally
the eggs i i have not eaten any meat
in 12 days
and my energy is
this all day long wow
3 30 in the afternoon for the last 25
years i crashed at 3 30. hard crash i
mean like
i'll see you guys uh call me later okay
what'd you do at 3 30. i got him i got a
meeting yeah that meeting was on that
nap dude and when i hit it i'm talking
coma
deep sleep
better than
sleep at night sometimes it would be 30
minutes sometimes it'd be an hour and a
half
like comatose 12 days i can't take a nap
i try to go take a nap i cannot fall
asleep
so i'll give my energy you think you're
gonna stick with this do you think
you'll have meat sometimes
i mean i'm not i'm not like i'm not a
fanatic guys so so it's a little meat
here and there or something i'm just
gonna eat what makes me feel best yeah
so i don't care if it was meat if it was
pork it was bacon but right now
as long as i can find the greens
and i haven't met i haven't missed the
meat wow
my digestion's better
you know
my energy is great
so
i don't know man
[Music]
if you want even more lessons from
billionaires check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you should just be yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said i was just going to be myself i
find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm i'm quite grumpy
i mean obviously i think most people
that way